hi there steve kaufman
this is going to be the first in a
series of seven videos where i deal with
each of the seven habits of highly
effective people that stephen covey uh
covers in his book and which i made
reference to in my video last week
uh the first well first of all i'll go
over very quickly the seven habits and
this is advice for people in their lives
advice for managers advice for business
people and and for people generally and
the stephen covey and you can google
stephen covey c-o-v-e-y
seven habits and you'll get a lot more
information but there are
seven habits the first three
uh have to do with independence the
second three have to do with
interdependence and the seventh one has
to do with constantly renewing yourself
and constantly improving so the first
one today i'm going to talk about is the
need to be proactive
i think it's true in many things in life
if we wait for things to happen to us
some things may have i mean many things
will happen to you
however by being proactive by taking
initiatives
by pursuing your goals uh it's more
likely that good things are going to
happen to you and certainly
i found in language learning that as
long as i was a passive learner in
school
uh with the teacher teaching me and as
long as i waited for the teacher somehow
or the textbook to teach me i wasn't
making very good progress
once i took control of my learning once
i went out and and this means looking
for
things in the language that interest me
books uh
in the case of chinese books with in
those days before the the internet books
with um vocabulary lists behind each
chapter
taking the initiative initiative in
terms of what i want to learn about what
aspects of the language i need to work
on uh taking the initiative
not to stay with the program
that the teacher is is
leading you
into in the classroom
many teachers don't like this they don't
want the students to get ahead of them
this is so wrong because
the language
isn't just chapter one chapter two
chapter three the language is is
basically a whole
package and we learn
we learn different parts of it again and
again and again and so for the student
to go out and find things of interest to
him or her and then go back and do what
they're doing in class all of this is
good you have to take the initiative you
have to take responsibility there are
people who say
that there's no bad learner there's only
a bad teacher i don't believe that at
all i think whether you're in a
classroom or whether you are studying on
your own
only those learners who take the
initiative who are motivated enough to
take charge of their learning are going
to be successful and
we have ample evidence of this in our
school system in canada and i'm sure in
other language schools where a small
percentage of the learners actually
improve
and
an equally large number can improve on
their own if they're motivated so that
the
important point is not the number of
instructional hours the important is
point is to what extent are you prepared
to be proactive and take charge of your
own learning so that's the first of the
seven habits that stephen covey talks
about and it might even be the most
important
be proactive take charge of your own
learning and that's the first of the
seven habits of highly effective people
thank you for listening bye for now